[Música]
y en directo vamos con nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica andrés
suárez para hablar del salvador del
gobierno del presidente en allí buque le
informó este martes que las autoridades
han capturado a más de 50.000 presuntos
pandilleros desde finales de marzo de
este año lo que motivó en seguida a que
la asamblea nacional de este país
aprobara por quinta vez consecutiva una
extensión de 30 días del régimen de
excepción que cuarta las libertades
constitucionales de los salvadoreños
andrés muy buenas noches cuéntenos qué
significa para el gobierno de el
salvador cruzar este umbral de 50 mil
presuntos pandilleros capturados y hasta
cuándo estará vigente en este país este
permanente estado de excepción
andrés muy buenas noches significa todo
un éxito porque este ha sido uno de los
pilares de la política internacional de
la política interior perdón del
presidente nadie bukele desde que asumió
la administración en
2019 de capturar a las pandillas las
denominadas maras en centroamérica estos
grupos delictivos organizados que se
formaron desde 1992 cuando terminó la
guerra civil de el salvador de acuerdo
con las últimas cifras del gobierno de
nadie nadie bukele se cuentan
aproximadamente
76 mil los pandilleros que durante
largos 30 años han asolado han minado la
percepción de seguridad de este país
centroamericano y aquí no es necesario
sacar la calculadora pero hay una
ecuación muy básica y es que teniendo en
cuenta que habían 16 mil pandilleros ya
en las cárceles tras las rejas más 50
mil que se han capturado a lo largo de
estos cinco meses de régimen decepción
pues ya son 66 mil los pandilleros que
están
bajo la administración de nadie bucle y
estarían a tan solo diez mil pandilleros
de lograr ese umbral es el número de
setenta y seis mil pandilleros lo
lograrán allí mujer será el primer
presidente del salvador bueno amanecerá
y veremos lo que si es que ya está
dispuesto todo un mecanismo de una mega
cárcel para más de 40 mil pandilleros
también procesos judiciales para que
sean estos pandilleros puestos en
prisión hasta por 45 años y pues se
viene un periodo de incertidumbre si se
llegara a más de seis meses de este
período de excepción
andrés y otra particularidad es que el
régimen de excepción que promueven allí
buque le ha provocado múltiples
denuncias de abuso de poder violaciones
de derechos humanos pero también ha
suscitado una efervescente popularidad
del presidente como se siente
actualmente la percepción de buques en
el salvador
bueno de acuerdo con la última encuesta
de la consultora gallup con sede en
costa rica de hace tan sólo tres semanas
la popularidad en el ebook que leer
ronda el
86% no es para nada fácil que un
presidente latinoamericano y hacienda
una popularidad de más del 85%
históricamente lo han logrado muy pocos
álvaro uribe en el 2018 presidente
colombiano con la crisis diplomática de
venezuela o por ejemplo danilo medina
presidente dominicano con el impulso que
le dio a la economía de los dominicanos
en el 2013 de manera que si es por
encuestas nadie buque l tiene una alta
popularidad y esto por cuenta de haber
disminuido drásticamente el número de
homicidios el número de extorsiones y
que se genere un aire de tranquilidad
sin embargo está la otra cara de la
moneda de los organismos internacionales
de los derechos humanos como amnistía
internacional human rights watch que
denuncian que hasta la fecha de esos 50
mil capturados hay centenares que no
tendrían nada que ver con las pandillas
70 personas que habrían muerto en manos
de las autoridades y desde ya pues se
presume que ha habido un abuso de poder
a lo largo de estos cinco meses de
régimen de excepción en el salvador
andrés gracias por ese reporte desde
antigua seguimos con más aquí en directo
américa